if you're a ceo and you're just driven
by business which you know entrepreneurs
really are
you've got to find a passion she wanted
to diversify her risk
is what she wanted because she didn't
she knew you were great but she didn't
know which one of your ideas was going
to hit
i'm so passionate i'd like to show you
how good i am
as someone who can create value for you
i know this sounds
what do you mean don't pay me
do you think there are common successful
attributes
in people and i guess what she's asking
is can you find a string of things that
that is the same for people that are
successful
do they all do the same thing well of
course they don't all do the same thing
but i have found over time
in working with lots of ceos and that's
business but also
artists musicians photographers
you know those kinds of watch collectors
there are some elements of their lives
that i find are consistent i want to
share them with you today
first of all this this concept of
priorities
now i learned this from you know a
woman's ceo years ago
to actually carry with you all the time
and i have it right here
if i don't have my big notebook i carry
a small one with me
paper just paper and
what i've got in here are notes and i
carry a pen with me all the time
i love to collect pens this is a new
egyptian moblong
when i know i when somebody hits me
wherever i am
i remember to write it down and the
reason i do that is i build a priority
set
that i put down each night and out of
all the priorities of the day i carry
three into the next day because you can
even see
here's a day you can see that a bunch of
stuff has been
a bunch of priorities there but i've i
basically
done them i got them done but this idea
of
prioritizing ends up being a really big
deal so that's attribute number one
politicians teachers generals ceos
they build a data set in their heads of
things they've got to get done
and they don't do anything else until
they've achieved those for me it's
sticking out on the mirror each night
i've talked about this countless times
and i don't do anything else till i get
those three done and they're built from
the list that i generate during the day
so
definitely for all successful people
regardless of what their discipline is
that idea of priority really matters
number two you may find this interesting
but it's
it's looking good and feeling good you
know i don't go out into the sun and
i've talked about them before
tiege hanley skin creams and things that
are really healthy for you
particularly for me spf at least spf 20.
you know i got the chrome dome i got to
make sure it's looking good all the time
before i came out here i put some
moisturizer on
so i dip into my kit my teach handling
kit i find my morning application
it's all right on here it says
moisturizer with spf 20.
exactly what i need protect
the dome don't let it burn around the
nose and the eyes
that easy and what i like about them is
they send me a kit it's got an
instruction card in it
i don't have to think it through
basically each vial or bottle or you
know
tube tells me exactly what it's for it's
really easy to implement it doesn't have
any smelly perfumes
which i hate so i'm constantly using it
you know because they're sponsoring this
this youtube video today i obviously ask
them for a deal
they're going to include a free toiletry
bag if you go to the first link in the
description you can get it there
check that out tiege hanley i endorse it
because i use it i don't endorse
products i don't use
but hey you got to have the dome looking
good all the time and
skin you've got to keep it moisturized
and you've got to keep it out of the sun
i don't care who you are
that really matters now something else
that's really important
is and i can't stress this enough and
the more i experience this with people
the more i believe it to be true you
have to have another passion besides the
one that is your discipline in other
words
if you're a teacher you have to do
something else but that's not teaching
if you're a ceo and you're just driven
by business which you know entrepreneurs
really are
you've got to find a passion that's
really
important and i don't care whether it's
music or whether it's
playing an instrument or it's collecting
watches i love to do that too
you can have multiple passions i you
know i love pens i love watches i love
guitars
i love photography they distract me
from the intensity of my core
discipline which is business i'm an
investor you know i'm an entrepreneur i
invest in companies i try and help them
work
and that gives me financial freedom
which of course is very important but
i got to do something else i have to and
you know that i find more and more is a
really big deal with successful people
they're very disciplined in what they do
well
in their main focus in life yes
but they've also got other passion it
can be a single passion or it can be
multiple
and that ying and yang which i've spoken
of so many times
is so important there's no question
about that you know when i really think
through
uh what what has helped me so much and
and those that i really follow and
that i admire you know everybody's got a
mentor
and there's always somebody that's more
successful than you and you can learn
from them
i don't care how successful you are
there's always somebody that's better
and you should realize that in your life
and that's okay there's always something
to learn
but those people to me look good they
feel good
they have priorities and they make sure
that they
attempt some kind of yin and yang i
didn't say
balance because if you're an
entrepreneur there's no balance you're
going to be working 25 hours a day
eight days a week i mean that's just the
way it is but you can find the time
to be productive in that way it doesn't
mean you know you abandon your family
and all that stuff i'm talking about the
intensity
of your focus and so i wanted to get
that out i really i really felt that you
know
answering i've got so many questions
along the same line that
that's basically the way i feel about it
it's not
it's not something that you immediately
find intuitive
but you will find over time that these
attributes matter so let's summarize
prioritization putting that list
together writing it down really works
looking good feeling good taking care of
yourself no question about it
you know being extremely focused on your
own discipline is great but have
other passions watch collecting love
that
i've talked about music all that stuff
you got to do all that you have to find
that ying and yang
and all of a sudden you'll find a new
energy that comes up
if you try and follow these disciplines
life's really interesting that way
you're always learning from it
[Music]
you know because we talk about
entrepreneurship so much in the journey
and the talent the challenge of doing it
i thought we'd bring on someone who's
actually been on shark tank
not once twice this guy's a crazy
chicken
and even to talk yourself on a shark
tank twice is impossible so he's done it
and who knows he might be the only
person to come on three times he's got
the energy
i'll let him introduce himself and then
we're going to take a whole bunch of
questions from
us mr wonderful viewers but we've got an
entrepreneur here
extraordinaire erin kevin thank you so
much no problem
so my name is aaron marino i have the
youtube channel alpha m and
basically from this channel it allowed
me to start
different verticals and different
businesses i think that at my core
i'm an entrepreneur it just happened
that my business
that i wanted to basically start from
the age of 12 was a fitness center i
knew at 12 years old what i wanted to do
for the rest of my life
you know everything leading up to the
point at which i actually opened a
fitness center
that's what it was about from 12 years
old i wanted to help people change their
lives and
you know as as you know entrepreneurship
is not a straight line
and it was it was the most devastating
thing
that happened when i had to end up
shutting the business down back in
2006 because poopoo happens well it
happens and it happened a lot i think
there there should have been an omen we
signed the lease
to our facility on the september 11th
that was pretty much a telltale sign of
how
everything was going to unfold i think
that's a very important list for
everybody listening because
just because you assume success just
because you have the energy just because
you have the desire
doesn't mean it's going to happen for
you in the first time in fact i believe
that entrepreneurs that go
through the sting of failure are
motivated in a very special way
afterwards and clearly in your case
that's been exactly what's happened
because
there's been a lot of [ __ ] hits you and
somehow
here we are you're very successful now
which is i'm so happy to have you on my
channel
because i want to talk a little bit
about that journey but you
actually have a unique amount of aura
and energy
and that's the reason that you've been
on shark tank twice because
when you came on the first time i
thought you were a real dick
i mean the idea was so preposterous the
idea that you were going to sell
a style system 300 bucks i know but dvds
yeah and the whole idea was so crazy
but because your your storytelling was
so compelling
you actually got people seriously
considering it i nearly had to go down
the line the other sharks and say look
no one's giving this guy any dough this
is way too crazy
but you were very good at explaining why
it might have value to somebody and
that's
part of the challenge of being an
entrepreneur to be able to explain your
opportunity
in a very short concise period of time
which you were very good at
but after that you came back
and which is remarkable and let's talk
about that experience what was that like
first of all being one i think it's less
than one percent ever get back yeah no
shark tank is is is amazing and it's a
it's a shame that that people don't
really understand like what really goes
into it they only see a small window of
what happens well here's a chance for
you to it is
brutal it is i mean and the one thing
that you're going to notice if i tell
you this
it sort of ruins it you your mouth gets
so dry when you're out there
because you're scared [ __ ] you're scared
shitless yeah and so you're there
and and and lights camera action and
there is no stop
there is no okay do that again it's like
go go go
and and you get grilled and that's what
i was not expecting i was not expecting
even though i watched it hundreds of
times i was not expecting
the questions to be not only as direct
and and sort of cut through all the
[ __ ] like it was this is what it's
about
you know and i wasn't prepared for that
even though i knew my numbers i was
prepared
and so the first time was kind of a
disaster i was so excited to be on
and i knew that i was gonna it didn't
matter what you guys said i knew that i
was going to sell a ton of style systems
afterwards
and the night the shark tank aired i had
all my friends and family there
everybody's there and i'm sitting there
and i had my my computer out and i was
ready to see that
that that dollar amount to start to to
ring and i sold
one unit the night the shark tank aired
like 80 million which by the way is
probably the worst
performance of any product ever in shark
tank history
because the idea sucked that's why and i
think i told you
because i am mr wonderful i tell the
truth it sucked
but you came back but so
the reality hit me in the face all right
this is not good
this is not working and so there i was
about a month later i knew that i needed
a lower price point product something
that every guy
needed because the deal was 300 bucks
right yeah 300 bucks
crazy it was it was an information shame
on you crazy
i sold one shut up you made hundreds of
dogs exactly i did i made hundreds and
so i was i was styling my hair when
inspiration struck my youtube channel
was all about helping guys look and feel
great
and hair products were one of those
things where i was passionate about and
i loved
and so i thought you know i'm going to
start a i'm going to start a hair
product business
and it's been sort of a wild ride ever
since
the youtube channel continues to grow i
came back on shark tank for the hair
product
and nobody wanted to invest in the
product no because first of all your
premise was for men
right yes which is a brutally
competitive space
and everybody's question was the same
what's your customer acquisition
strategy because you're competing with
some of the giants
on earth some of the biggest companies
on earth are in this space
and they're beating each other up and
here you are aaron saying hey hey
i'm here for a second time on shark take
i've got another crazy idea
please give me some money but i got it i
got to defend myself for a second
if anybody else would have gone in the
shark tank if they if i didn't have
the the backing or the reason i was
selling was because of my youtube
channel
if i went in there or entrepreneur went
in there with a business that in two
years made a million dollars it does
and and the margins were great growing
at a fast rate
everybody would have been throwing money
at them but because i had this
we didn't have the future in front of us
we only had your
second idea the first one absolutely
sucked
we all remembered that and we're
thinking why is this guy back the reason
you were back
is you are tremendously good television
which is a great message to everybody
out there
you have such energy in such an aura and
the camera likes you so much
that the producer said one more time
with feeling from the sky because
everybody knows sometimes the second
time up at bat is when you hit the home
run
and so i did i i got a deal with barbara
but she didn't want to invest in the
in the hair product business yeah
because she still thought it sucked no
she didn't think it sucked she but she
was investing into your point
she wanted a piece of my my youtube
channel now this was
she wanted to diversify her risk is what
she wanted because she didn't
she knew you were great but she didn't
know which one of your ideas was going
to hit
which is fair i'll speak for her i would
have done the same thing with you in
fact i would have been much tougher
but the point was that she was saying
look i know something's going to work
for this guy because he's got such an
incredible amount of energy
i don't know what it's going to be and
that's exactly what happened so fast
forward i didn't end up taking the deal
um since then i've been able to start a
few other businesses
um basically leveraging my my ability to
you know communicate and and have a
large following so which ones actually
worked the hair product business worked
it's uh what are the sales of that thing
right now this past year
barbara you bozo you let that get away i
can't believe it
shame on you let's imagine that dog that
piece of poopoo was doing
a million dollars that's it i didn't
think we were gonna get to the numbers
so that was one
why not i'm all about nothing that's not
and so that's that's that's not
so i have other businesses as well um i
don't want to go into the numbers with
all of them
that's a pretty good number that's a
pretty good number for a product that we
thought was going to suck so then my
largest business is a skincare company
called tiege hanley
that is a men's skincare subscription
business
i have a advertising agency that i
started as a result
of not being able to sell my
i didn't want to sell advertising to my
channel i wanted somebody else to do it
and so i hired my best friend from high
school terry
who is a car salesman an amazing car
salesman and from
moment one everything took off in terms
of you know sponsorship so just just
tease us what's the big nut what are you
gonna do in sales this year across all
this stuff
a lot like just give me a number i mean
a lot come on
see see here's where here's where listen
a lot is
can mean two dollars it's more than one
dollar that's a lot or it can mean
something substantive what do you got
what about you come on listen i'm asking
you
you're the one that got out of the team
yeah yeah and i want barbara to hear
just how yeah
you know eight figures in that and that
and that more than 10 million
more than 10 million more than 20
million more than we'll just get let's
just leave it there
barbara barbara barbara i'm going to buy
you a new broom so you can fly here
right now
to meet aaron again new broom for you
barbara right over here you can
fly she can fly on a broom she could hey
you know what love barbara but uh but no
everything
everything is great um i am incredibly
fortunate that i get to
do what i love every day which is create
content and the fact that
you know being an entrepreneur and
having that in my dna in my blood
you know you never know where
opportunity and the you never know which
one is going to work exactly and you got
to keep your eyes open because
but that's why i'm glad we're here today
together because we've got i get
thousands of questions from
entrepreneurs that we're actually at the
beginning of your journey maybe they've
failed once maybe they haven't even
started yet
that's why i want to tap into you today
on these ask mister wonderful questions
i got a bunch of them here
let's listen and then i want us both to
answer them from the different
perspectives we have
because you have come out of a hole you
have a little story on this watch before
we start right
this is a beautiful rolex you know i'm a
watch collector i really appreciate that
it's a gorgeous rose gold piece
but it's got an inscription on the back
of it what does it say yeah um
most people it's funny most people
celebrate
victories or wins or benchmarks in their
business by
by buying nice watches or they'll buy a
watch
to represent some some deal that's what
i do that's what i do
something good and a celebration of
success i bought this watch when things
were
bad in terms of and and bad is relative
because that's not a cheap piece
no but i i had my eye on it and i was
going through sort of a low point in
terms of
emotionally you know things with youtube
weren't going in the direction that i
wanted
but i bought it to remind myself that as
long as i keep trying as long as i don't
stop
it'll get better and i can do this and
so on
the back i i uh i had inscribed get to
work
and so everybody told me well that
devalues get to work it says get to work
figure it out i initially i would have
said that would have devalued the watch
except
since then maybe that watch is your
lucky timepiece because look what's
happened to you
and you look at it every day and you
remind yourself what you put on the back
of that at your low point
i love that story watches are about
conversations we just had one so that's
a very successful piece for you
because every time someone looks at and
says oh i really like that watch you can
tell them the story of that
absolutely that's great i love it i love
that too that's great
let's get to some questions okay cause
we're gonna have some fun here
i mean i love the fact that you can
relate and i i've not listened to these
questions so they're me neither
so we're ready let's go hi mr wonderful
big fan of the show and all the great
insights you've always given i'm a 24
year old recent business school grad
working as a business development
representative at a fashion tech startup
that uses ai to automate the fashion
photography process
here in new york city i finished college
with more debt than originally planned
around 21 000. i want to save and invest
in the future so i can start my own
business one day
i believe i need to eliminate all my
debt before saving and investing
and of course eventually starting my own
business do you recommend someone in my
opinion my position to focus all their
extra money
their savings and commissions towards my
student debt
or is it advantageous to do a little bit
of both save and invest
as well as pay off the debt even if
it'll take more time
thanks mr wonderful i've always
resonated with your story growing up as
an expat with you and myself
i love your videos any advice would be
great thanks you know what's cool about
this question it's in your space it's in
fashion
a little bit yeah but the guy is 21 000
in the hole
he hasn't even brought any revenue in
doesn't have a business yet what do you
tell
so for me i think it really depends on
for one
interest rate on that on that on that
student loan seven percent
seven percent um i would probably not
wait to start
saving for both my my future in terms of
my my business it sounds like
he's an entrepreneur he has an idea that
he wants to go after
um i would pay down the debt but i think
that i would
be utilizing my my funds to try to start
that business that i
that i ultimately feel will propel me
towards success
but so that freaks you out is what
you're saying i
i don't have any debt once i i had to
file bankruptcy
so you you felt i felt oh god you felt
the
terror of that there's nothing there's
nothing that takes the fun
out of life like debt and not knowing
how you're going to pay your
well said and and for me when i had my
fitness center and it was failing
i was taking money off of my credit
cards to pay my staff i mean it was
bad and at that point i had to drive i
was driving a beer cart to put gas in my
car at a country club
and here i am a 30 year old guy who has
a business a fitness center that i was
trying to franchise
and i'm driving a beer cart and the
worst part about it kevin
i didn't have a plan b i'm the type of
entrepreneur
that i don't have a safety net on plan a
all the time
direct and when that exploded i knew a
[ __ ] idea what i was gonna do
and that was the scariest part for me so
i totally agree with you
in that i share i have no debt zero
and every time my credit card comes in
every month every cent is paid off
because i live in fear of debt i've been
through that too
i didn't get to bankruptcy but i got
very close and it scared the living [ __ ]
out of me
and it made me feel unhealthy it put so
much stress on you
so i think both of us giving the same
advice number one focus is pay down that
21 000
but don't give up your dream you have an
interesting idea in fashion using ai
i love entrepreneurs with disruptive
ideas he's got one but that debt thing
is a real message in that question it is
absolutely
and so to you know that's for everybody
with with college debt it's between six
and seven percent most of these loans
they kick up to that rate pretty damn
fast
and you've got to start focusing on
whatever you're doing take 20 10
and pay it down there's also but there's
something also exciting about that
because he's in this new space
and so you know there's with startups
there's there is that entrepreneurial
spirit
and so you know that there there's also
the idea that if this hits
it could hit big but there's also a
tremendous amount of risk
may not hit exactly the risk with a
startup or something that's unproven
you know everybody's looking for that
exit and i really think that with
certain
businesses you really just need to be
smart and disciplined with
the way that you spend your money and
not think that and not assume that it's
going to hit
super big and so just be careful pay
your debt down because being debt free
is the most liberating feeling you'll
ever have well said let's get another
question here i'm sorry
am i talking more than you though i'm
cool with it i love the fact that we're
doing this together because at the end
of the day you've lived that ride you've
gone through it and so this is great
advice
let's listen to this one again i've
never heard these questions so i love
the fact that just
hey mr wonderful joe here huge fan
you're my favorite shark i was just
wondering what you do when the woman you
love will never love you back
thanks mr wonderful whoa joe baby
you know this is a good question it's a
great question you know i'll tell you
something in life when you fall in love
with somebody and they don't return that
that can be a bad affliction because it
really drags your energy down
but at some point you have to be honest
with yourself particularly when you have
that conversation with them
say look is there any chance between the
two of us all of us have been there
people try and say oh it's never
happened to me [ __ ] it happens to
everybody
but that makes you realize they're not
your partner they're not
there for you they don't love you back
and that's just the nature of love it's
a [ __ ] that way
but you have to have that conversation
with him this is my advice to joe
and say look i really have some strong
feelings for you but if you if you can
never reciprocate that
this is a bonnie rate song by the way
it's a classic which
professors are love to somebody and
they're never gonna love her back broke
her heart
what do you do joe my advice to you is
you gotta be honest the fact is you are
amazing
right you're an incredible guy and
you're gonna make some woman the
luckiest woman ever
but one of the issues that we fall into
as men is that we do get
sort of tied in and preoccupied with
that one person right
and really it's because of something
that we can't have right the truth is
you need to read the writing on the wall
and and it's time for you to take care
of yourself
and understand that you're never
ultimately going to find that perfect
person that's out there for you
until you are able to shut the door on
on this this person that
that obviously is not worthy of your
love and affection
do you think you should get a little
older aaron that you understand the
pitfalls of love and you start to
realize
i don't want to drag myself maybe you
maybe you become more of an oyster you
protect your emotions because they know
how much it hurts
but if you've never been hurt you can
never really fall in love absolutely
that's the issue that's the issue so i
think for joe
you got to write this one off and you
got to move on aaron has the right
advice there there's always another fish
in the ocean somewhere
by the way is she really smoking hot
that's breaking your heart that's the
problem
you know you know usually that's
yourself i'll never meet someone that
hot
you will you absolutely you will joe
it's
you will uh that's that's a tough one
okay here we go number three
i'm having fun are you i'm having a
blast it's great
all right here we go hi mr wonderful
thanks for taking my question
i wondered when do you know when is it a
good time to add a co-founder to your
company
and how much do you offer them i have a
company that i started about a year ago
and i think i am ready to add a
co-founder to the company
but not sure how much i should offer
them and
so i thought i would ask you mr
wonderful thanks so much
you know it's a great question what is
it co-founder is it really a co-founder
no it isn't it's a partner she's talking
about it but i mean here's the real
debate
that i've learned you know you're really
good at some things
and not good at others every
entrepreneur is exactly that way
so i'm i'm a good sales marketing person
i hate logistics and manufacturing
bores the [ __ ] out of me but without
that skill set i can't really scale
so along the way in my businesses i've
always found someone who
can make up for my weaknesses and i've
made them partners by giving them equity
they're not really co-founders as you've
said
but in order for them to stick to the
hard times and really suffer the pains
and slings and arrows of building a
business
you've got to give them a piece of the
action that's the way i look at it so if
you are actually growing and it's
working
and you realize you have weaknesses
you've got to find someone else to fill
those holes now maybe you can find
employees we're going to have to pay
them a lot i prefer to have people with
skin in the game
soldiers beside me we're all fighting
the same war together
and we're in for the mission and we all
get the upside so
i think if you're asking me this
question right now and i'm dying to hear
what aaron has to say
i think you're ready for a partner but
make sure you're not greedy don't be a
greedy pig
pigs got slaughtered if you're if you're
giving away equity
make sure it's the right person take a
long time to make that decision
but together you'll make a much bigger
pie and that equity will be worth a lot
to both of you what do you say
the one thing i would say i have some
businesses that i have partners in some
businesses that i don't
and there are upsides to both both
scenarios
the one thing i would say whenever you
are considering
adding somebody to the team to something
that you're building your baby
you want to make sure that it's not only
the right fit now but it's the right fit
moving forward and what i mean by that
is i think too often people are thinking
i need to give away
too much too soon and they think it's
you know it has to best like immediately
i would say that in this scenario find
somebody that is going to add value
that's going to fulfill
or fill the voids in which you know
you're not good at
and um and then do it over time do it
gradually there's nothing wrong with
seeing how this person performs
because the worst scenario so give them
the equity as they perform as they
perform have it best
over two years a year give them you know
certain a little bit of equity you know
after year one year two
have different benchmarks and really
because everybody's going to sell you
how great they are everybody is going to
tell you i'm amazing i can do this i can
do that
but the truth is it's put up or shut up
and in business
you know talk is cheap you've got to
actually execute
and and you've got to make sure that the
person that has told you
how excellent they are at executing is
actually able to do it and help your
business move forward and if it's not
well then that's not you're you're cool
with giving a piece of the play oh
absolutely
you see the merit in doing that oh 100 i
do too but i like your strategy if you
if you layer it in that's fine but by
that time it may be more
employees or maybe more people that have
to share and that's what options
generally
companies put about 15 of their equity
into people are coming on to grow it
you love to have that problem if you're
actually giving away equity because you
need more help
that means you're growing that's a
wonderful outcome i wish them good luck
on that one that's very cool
all right let's go to the next one
i'm having so much fun with this all
right here we go
me too kevin hi mr wonderful my name is
tara and i was wondering if you could
give me
well me and my husband a little bit of
advice on dressing for job interviews
we're both actually interviewing
at new companies this month and neither
of us have
been in the job interview game for for
probably five years or more
i've heard that wearing a suit and tie
or a blazer and heels for a woman used
to be the way to go but that some new
companies can
think that you're stuffy or won't fit
the job culture
um yeah we would love your advice is it
better to overdress
or is it better to be cool and
approachable
you're always fashionable and i know
you've talked a lot about
dressing for your job before so we would
love to get your advice
thank you well tara you've come to the
right place i have the fashionista man
right beside me here
erin i'm going to let you take a stab at
this sure she's raising a really good
question for
both men and women yeah they're back in
the job market they want to look sharp
they want to win the job basically i
think the the first thing you need to
do is do your research figure out what
the corporate culture is like at the the
place that you're actually applying for
because
one of the issues if you're going to
like a cool like tech startup i i really
feel like it does
to some degree depend on the the
the business that you're actually going
and applying for
um and so do your research if it's a
cool tech startup in the valley
what are you saying you're going to be a
little hipper in terms of what clothing
you're wearing
a little more free you don't have the
pressure to dress it might not
require a suit and tie a something super
professional
it might be a business casual or a
business casual type of environment
but i always would say err on the side
of overdressing versus under dressing
100 of the time
that is your one shot and your employer
knows that it doesn't get any better
than right now like this is the best if
you are going in for an interview you
know
that if this person didn't shave if you
know this person
didn't you know didn't wear pantyhose or
whatever the situation is
it's never getting any better and so i
would say that
you if you want to dress and be cool and
hip later that's fine that's for hr to
work out but right now you need to be
respectful
of the position you're going after but
also do your due diligence
in identifying what the corporate
culture is because if you go in
in a three-piece suit and it doesn't
require that you may
be overdressing for the potential job or
interview
it's a great answer i'm going to take a
stab at it too because i actually
interview a lot of people
and and i've learned that the the key
words you just brought up there
and you only get first time to do a
first impression only once
that only happens once when you walk in
that room and you look at each
other so clothing is really interesting
because
it's different for men and women men
have fewer choices particularly if
you're going for a job in financial
services
what's happened on both the east and the
west coast over the last five years is
the tie has come back
as a sign of respect that you care
if you're in the financial services
you're in an industry of trust
and the styles have become very very
clean
and the tie and also you know
the the colors have become more muted
it's very interesting to watch that
happen it happens in san francisco los
angeles i see it in new york miami
chicago
and i travel all those cities people are
looking crisp
clean and subtle for them for the side
of men now women this is very
controversial because
if you look at some of the codes that
are now written by large corporations
about women's clothing
they're putting in the concept of not
showing too much
chest they don't want controversial
dressing they don't want it to be
flirtatious
because of all the me too things that
are going on in the world and they're
trying to tone down
and believe me in big companies people
meet each other and stuff happens that's
just men and women doing their thing
but how you clothe if it's caught if you
clothe yourself in a controversial way
that's going to hurt you in a job
interview are they risking something
that's the employer saying themselves
and they make notes about this stuff i
can guarantee you and very often they're
asking for a picture of you before you
show up
just so they can see what you're wearing
women have to be very
careful that they look professional
that's what matters whatever that means
to you
taking into account your idea about the
company you're going to work in
but if you come in with anything
controversial that hurts
and that's why they're dress codes and
that's why companies as they grow
just past 25 people hr starts to put in
place dress codes
because they don't want to cause tension
in the workplace great
question though i loved it never had one
like that before and good it came when
you were on the set
because you're the fashionista guy you
keep telling me that you overestimate my
abilities yeah come on
you told me twice on shark tank remember
all right
hi mr wonderful this is andres from
colombia
at the moment my brother and i have a
hamburger and a hot dog
business with three outlets my question
is
if it is better to grow slowly or seek
funds to grow faster
we are selling over a million dollars a
year we've been open for two years only
thank you a million bucks and three
stands
the kid knows what he's doing you can
live off that
you're good you're probably making about
30 margin on product like that
i would think you know bringing in 300
000 maybe it's between 200 300 000 i'm
going to give him that if he's running
it
so that's a good question you first you
go all right you borrow money to expand
or you just grow
slow and steady so here's the thing that
you got to figure out
if you raise money how are you going to
use that money
in order to take your business to that
next level one of the big mistakes that
i see
a lot of entrepreneurs and businesses
get into is they take money because they
think hey i need more money
but they don't know how they're going to
spend it in order to actually generate
more revenue i am a firm believer that
you never
you know it sort of goes back to the
whole debt thing i don't want that on my
personal life i don't want that in my
business
unless i know if i can use and you've
said this all the time i just want to
add fuel to the fire
right or or cash to the fire and make it
burn bigger gasoline to the phone that's
what it is and so
unless you know how you're going to
spend that money and you've got the
the infrastructure in place in order to
be able to scale your business
bigger stronger more profitable based on
you taking money
i say until you know how you're going to
do that
until you have a roadmap of i'm going to
spend x
i'm going to get this back don't take
the money do not fall into the trap
because if you take money from
friends and family they'll let it slide
but once you go into that institutional
money
then they're calling you and they're
like hey why aren't you selling 27 more
burgers a day
and do you want to answer to those
people that's my question to you
i i think it's a great question because
clearly they figured out the model three
stands doing a million bucks i'm going
to say that they're probably making
250 000 pre-tax on that
it can be a pretty good margin business
you're selling direct to the customer
cash
so you don't have a lot of credit you
have to worry about or bad loans or
anything else
what i would do is i would open one more
stand using the cash flow of the other
three in a very close geography in other
words just make it a place that you can
actually go visit every day
i love businesses that spin cash and you
can live off
i hate debt so it's just what happens is
you have to start hiring people relying
on them to have the same fire you have
that maintain these stances sounds like
a bit of a family business which i think
is terrific
you don't have to become mcdonald's to
have a successful business
so i would cool it i'd open one more
with the cash you've got then one after
that
grow it slowly zero debt
that's for other people not you my
friend but a great question
great answer yeah great answer kevin
it's like you've done this before yeah
well i hate that just like you do okay
here we go
one more time with feeling erin i'm here
what is the biggest deal you made on
shark tank
that's a simple question right saying no
to aaron that was my biggest deal
and it was a huge mistake the guy's
rocking around with maybe 20 million in
sales it's more of barbara's problem
she's the one that missed
it the largest deal in shark tank
history actually is mine it's the
the company called plated um and it's
measured by the biggest accident it was
300 million dollars
they came on shark tank did not get a
deal they were asking for such a
ridiculous valuation two guys just like
you we ran into them a year later
in the streets of new york they taught
they told me where they were at and they
said look we'd love to get a shark into
the deal
and i then did the deal a year
afterwards and that was sold only
24 months after that to albertsons for
300 million
so they had nothing when they came on
shark tank that's the biggest acts that
we've seen so far in shark tank history
but it just shows you
the dream is alive you can come on shark
tank with a great
idea you know get an investment from a
shark and together we can use the
platform to blow it up big there's been
so many cases of that
and great entrepreneurs show up every
day and you know all joking aside
aaron's probably one of the best
examples of what it takes to get on
shark tank you need energy you
need you need to show that you really
care and are passionate about the
business
as he was and he got on twice now
barbara screwed up that's her problem
hi mr wonderful my main question is
how do you make money with no money also
how do you come up with a good business
idea
it seems like there's just too much
competition everywhere
and all the good business ideas are
taken
andrea don't sound depressed i don't
like that tone
i'll tell you something nobody has a
monopoly on great ideas nobody there's
always somebody with a problem that
needs to be solved and that is the
essence
of a great business opportunity look
around you in the world and see the
problems people are having
keep your eyes open and when you
discover one that you think you can fix
that is the beginning of a business my
friend that's how it starts
so don't be down and don't say that all
the great ideas are taken that's never
the case
there's always the next great idea and
that's what's wonderful about being an
entrepreneur you got to keep sort of
your mind open and your eyes open and
always be looking for opportunity
and don't be depressed i don't like that
tone let's get happy
and let's get focused and let's get to
work and by the way
the greatest companies ever started were
many that were started with no money
it's not about money it's about solving
somebody's problem if you can solve a
problem you can start a business
even with no cash you're going to
provide as much as you can for the
little as you can to start it and prove
it out
you got a product or service that people
are buying and they're saying this works
for me you're solving a problem
that's the beginning of a great journey
good luck my friend
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello mr wonderful if you were mid 20s
again with no debt
and 300k liquid cash that's currently
being invested
uh what would you do with it oh
definitely i mean look it's a great
question 300k
that's a lot of dough i'm impressed i
don't know how you got that but it
sounds pretty good
um at that young age i would generally
go into more equities than fixed income
because you've got a very long horizon
but the key is the market's at all-time
highs these days so you've got to layer
in you can't put it all to work at the
same time
i would put 15 to work today and wait
three months then put another 15 to work
you know you kind of
you just don't know when there's going
to be a correction and if you go in over
a long period of time
you'll buy some at lower prices than
than they are today maybe and i don't
know this nobody does that's the whole
point
but the key to successful investing is
diversification that's why i like to use
etfs exchange traded funds that have
many many stocks in one ticker
they're inexpensive and very low cost
and what i like about them is they're
transparent they're very tax efficient
that's probably the easiest way to do it
but definitely prices have really gone
up quite a bit and you kind of want to
wait
um i think and put in fifteen percent
fifty percent three months later maybe
fifty percent three months after that
and keep some cash around because you
don't know what's going to happen great
investing is around
you know investing when things are low
and waiting for them to go higher
but you never know what the market's
going to do so larian over time
great question though thank you
[Music]
instead of an almond brother's kind of
bluesy
kind of thing perfect to set up for
george
let's see what he's got hello mr william
my name is george kuchi shreely calling
it from california
i'm 21 years of age and i've always
known
that i've wanted to be an entrepreneur
the only issue is
i cannot find my passion if you watch
any youtube video
this the main advice they give you is
find your passion and
excel in it the thing is i know i can
excel in anything i put my mind into
but i don't know what to put it into so
my question would be
how can you identify this passion what's
the best way of exposing yourself
to to certain situations that may
give you a spark or something george
well i should call you passionless
george don't worry about
finding the passion the the key
to entrepreneurship is to really look
for opportunity
and what i think is great is instead of
just saying i'm going to start up on my
own
when you find something you're
interested in whether it be technology
or manufacturing or the arts or whatever
it is
be an apprentice for a year this is old
school
that way you can find out if the passion
is really in you you can actually steep
yourself in and say look i'm a really
good worker
let's say you find a company you want to
work for you go and see the ceo the man
or woman running and say
you don't have to pay me i'm so
passionate i'd like to show you how good
i am
as someone who can create value for you
i know this sounds
what do you mean don't pay me when when
i you know when i meet somebody comes up
to me says i want to work for one of
your companies and i'll do it for free
because i'm
so good at what i do and i can make
things much better for you
i can solve problems i can enhance
profits i can help you
achieve your goals you don't think i
listen to that there's somebody that's
got passion
passion to try and work and help and of
course if they can actually achieve the
things they're talking about i'm going
to hire them
apprentice gets you in the door is my
point and you don't have to know with
certainty
what it is that you love but you've got
to go
try and the key is apprenticeship
i got lots of people that work for me
for nothing just because they get
exposed to all the things that we do
around all the companies i'm an investor
in and those are the men and women i
think are just terrific because
they're they're they're in it because
they want to try
you think about that
[Music]
this is from cindy rose hi mr wonderful
i got into your channel recently and
have watched the last seven episodes
you spend a lot of time talking about
the traits of successful people
and for the most part i have enjoyed the
shows
but you really leave a lot out what
about
diet what about exercise what about
fashion what about grooming what about
drugs what about alcohol
what about sleep i'm interested in where
all these fit into a successful
lifestyle
i really think you should take the time
to answer these questions
because i'm going to bet many other
people want the same
information okay
grooming this is an interesting one
i feel that when you get up in the
morning
and you work out you know my routine is
i get up i work out i have breakfast i
get it pretty early
i get a lot of work done early on i get
my three things done
but before i go out particularly if i'm
gonna spend time outside
one of the problems i've got is i'm
always putting on
makeup i have makeup on right now
generally i put it on and i got a lot of
real estate you don't want to be shiny
on tv so i'm putting this stuff on my
you know my my golden dome a lot
and a ton of it under my eyes like this
and around my nose and here where it
gets shiny
if you see people that are on tv they
look great on the camera when you see
them in person
they come off the set they look like
they're dead they got so much makeup
packed on you know i don't endorse
products that i don't use personally
i just don't want to do it if i'm going
to get a sponsor which i have
you know on my youtube channel i'm going
to use the product i want to know all
about it
and i want it to work for me why would i
endorse it for somebody else if i don't
try it on myself you got to eat your own
cooking i really believe that
teach hanley has a scrub that i've
really
started to use and i'm particularly
around you know my eyes and my nose
and i mean you know it sounds crazy
talking about this but
it actually become part of my routine
the wash is a basic wash for your face
morning or night for me and the scrub
takes all the crap
out of my pores skin care for men who
knew
i'm using it now because i want to keep
looking like mr wonderful
and naturally when i invite tiege hanley
to be a sponsor of my video because they
use their products
i want them to give a little certain
sequoia
to my base i want them to give you a
deal i want them to give you something
extra special
so they're sponsoring this video today
they're hooking up my viewers with a
special offer just click on the first
link
in the description to get a free
toiletry drop bag with your first box
so i you know i do a shout out for their
products because they work and i hate
perfumey stuff
and theirs isn't so i i don't want you
know a smell coming off it
it's just clean good stuff so i'm you
know i'm shameless endorsement for them
but
it's good i bring it to the idea of
grooming i'll tell you why
in your career in doing deals and being
an entrepreneur and being a leader in
being a great employee whatever you're
gonna do
you want to walk into a room and you
want to feel good you want to look good
and that involves grooming and fashion
finding out what you like to feel like
what you how you want to present
yourself
when it comes to financial services like
oh shares and bean stocks and all the
fintech stuff i invest in
and i'm in new york i'm in la or i'm in
zurich or i'm in london and i travel to
these places
for business i like the crisp suit
look i got a classic look some people
think i'm nuts it's always the same i
got 25 of the same suits 25 of the same
shirts 25 type ins
25 black ties i vary my watches as you
know they all have red bands
and i've got a very broad collection of
watches but consistency is the red band
that's my thing
and i you know change my watch almost
every day sometimes three times a day
depends where i'm where i'm what i'm
doing you know i travel with watches and
i like to have a
sort of a fashion look and people say
well that's kind of nuts why would you
need more than one watch why would you
need to watch it all why don't you just
um use your phone and get the perfect
time off your phone it's always accurate
i get that
i like the fashion statement i like the
the art in the dial
i like the way it works with the
cufflinks so that's that's a that's a
grooming slash fashion thing
and you got to find your groove you got
to find your look you can shake it up
but people get to know you about whether
you've got that
that vibe that fashion vibe
you know take barbara corcoran
i know about her she always is dressed
real sharp
i mean she always looks spectacular
lori the same way these women know how
to present themselves and they have a
look
barbara's different than lori but i'm
just making an example of people i've
been working with for 12 years
i know when they walk out i'm not just
talking about
on the shark tank set you go to anywhere
with either of them and they are
dressed to kill i get it that's a
certain persona that they're projecting
that's a certain look i look around the
other sharks damon
really into some eclectic style but
that's his thing means the fubu guy
robert has a west coast breezy kind of
thing these are all
and of course cuban likes to just wear
sweats because he's saying something
with that
he can wear anything he wants that's
what he's saying and i get that too
but the point is it becomes a little bit
about who you are
and i think you should spend some time
thinking about it
and and you don't need a lot of really
expensive stuff
and i always air towards buying
something really good and having less
of it you don't need like 15 jeans you
need
three fantastic pair you don't need 20
leather jackets maybe you need two
i mean that's my whole point my suit
thing i like the consistency of my look
so i wear that
you know i've gone overboard on watches
but that's just my own thing
but i'm trying to make a point about
something here that becomes part of who
you are and it happens to you
in your late teens you start to get a
feel for the way you want to project
yourself and i think that's very cool
i think it's really really worth
thinking about make that decision
consult with others there's so much
stuff online obviously but it's
it's what makes you feel good
you know that's that's what really
matters what makes you feel good what
makes you confident to walk out there
and do your
thing that's how you should groom
and that's how you should fashion up you
kind of have to make up your mind
how you want to present yourself and if
you're comfortable with the way you look
be cool with it that's it i mean look it
doesn't
it doesn't mean it's going to affect
your performance that's not the case
unless you're some kind of fine-tuned
athlete or something
but i also don't want to let it drag me
down in terms of how i feel and how much
energy i've got
i care about energy levels that's what
matters if you're an entrepreneur
if you if you really want to if you want
to run
you got to have some energy and
sometimes and when i mean run i mean you
want to run through your day i don't
mean running around you can do that too
as exercise
energy to me and weight are somehow
combined and you know
i like everybody else tried dieting i
tried all the apps
what i found works is you have to get
into a lifestyle groove
um because weight is really
very simple equation calories in
calories out
and depending on how much you burn a day
whether you're burning 1600 1800
2100 whatever it is you're going to
either gain or lose weight but you want
to keep constant weights so you got to
kind of think about that
in the context of what you're eating all
day long because maybe i want only 2 000
calories a day
i don't want it to be 50 in wine so i
have to constrain myself in terms of how
much wine i actually drink
but my point is if you get into a groove
where you have to me i have a normal
breakfast i got to eat something in the
morning
right after i work out and then i don't
eat anything again until lunch
and it's those in between periods of
snacking
and eating crap that's no good for you
that really
helps you keep weight off or packs it on
over a long period of time you've got to
look at it that way
i don't really buy into the super diet
taking all the supplements and all that
stuff
i believe in good food i believe in food
and moderation but
i really want to be able to try
everything wherever i go
and just be pragmatic about it you know
if there's certain things that you're
allergic to
or you know non-dairy and all that and
then everybody says to me why don't you
become a vegan well i am a vegan
i'm a modified vegan i don't eat meat on
tuesday from
breakfast till noon hey it's my my tip
of the hat to vegans
i eat less red meat i eat more fish i
eat more chicken
i moderate it all but yes i'm modified
vegan
i like to say that anyways
my point is you got to eat well
not too much of any one thing and if you
can
you know and if you want to modify your
weight you have to do it over a
really long period of time like set a
goal of losing seven or eight pounds
in six months that's my you know you all
these diets you crash diet loses crash
diet with that that's all you can do is
crash
you got to just modify your eating
habits slightly and it has a big impact
over a period of time
okay so let me tie that to alcohol for a
second because i want to talk a little
bit more about that
and i like cindy rose's question about
how this fits into a
successful lifestyle let's talk about
alcohol
let me give you some do's and don'ts
just from my point of view
okay i'm in the wine business i drink
but i never
do it when i'm working why
because it only takes one mistake
and you get cancelled and i don't mean
just cancelled off tv you can get
canceled out of life
you've seen it happen social media is
cruel
people get drunk they say stupid things
maybe you shouldn't tweet maybe you
shouldn't go to insta when you're
drinking maybe you should really think
it through before you become
public while you're relaxing
i'm not saying getting drunk but just
some rules about drinking here's some
other rules
i've interviewed thousands of people in
my time
i've never hired anybody where i could
smell alcohol on their breath
not because i think they're alcoholics
not at all
in my view this is a personal opinion
they didn't take that interview very
seriously if they had a drink beforehand
or maybe they had nerves and they
couldn't do the interview without having
a drink
that also i don't like in life you're
going to have to make decisions about
this stuff
and when you drink and basically for
most stuff you drink
people can smell it if no one else in
the room has had anything to drink and
you have
people are going to smell it what does
that say about you
in my view not good things because
you've done it during the work day
now in europe sometimes when i go over
there to do business around wine
and i'm in with with others in the
winemaking industry yeah we drink at
lunch i mean that's you know it's
sometimes a burgundian or you know if
you're in bordeaux that
that's happening but you're dealing with
the craft of making wine and you're in
the wine business
slightly different i'm in new york city
having a meeting with an executive or
talking to a producer about something
i'm working on a television
at one in the afternoon i'm not drinking
i'm just not going to do it i can wait
and when the market's over for me my
routine is 4 4
30. i've been doing this ever since i've
been involved in financial services
yeah i'll go have a drink with somebody
and that's after the market's over
i don't drive anywhere after that i'll
tell you that but this thing with
alcohol is kind of weird and i'll tell
you why i say it
i've got lots of friends that have
completely stopped drinking altogether
and i know why
not necessarily full-blown alcoholics
but it changed their personality they
were different people even after a
couple of glasses of wine they were not
their original self and what would
happen is
the next day someone would say to them
you know hey listen um
you know last night were you drunk do
you remember saying this or that
if that starts happening to you alcohol
is actually
changing your behavior if it happens
consistently
and people comment about it to you
you could have a problem not necessarily
being an alcoholic but letting something
like that
change other people's perception of you
alcoholism breaks up families destroys
wealth
causes huge fractions between friends
sometimes for lifetime periods
nothing tastes that good that it's worth
destroying your life over i don't care
what booze you're talking about
do not let alcohol define who you
are that's my advice on that great segue
into drugs
okay now drugs is a whole
different ballgame i don't do drugs
because
i don't like what it does
to my abilities to process information
my day is packed with stuff that i deal
with sometimes it's problems sometimes
it's opportunities
i don't want to make decisions when my
thinking is altered
now i know there's a huge debate about
cannabis and the merits of it
and all that i never invested in
cannabis why because
all the companies that showed me deals
never were able to separate
the medicinal opportunities should there
be one with cbds etc
and recreational i don't invest in
recreational marijuana because it's not
legal in every state and i do business
in every state
and there's something called the rico
statute and it's a schedule one narcotic
i don't want to fight with that stuff i
don't want to be involved in it so i
don't do it
and i don't invest in it someone said to
me recently hey wait a minute
didn't you invest in psychedelics
yeah i did i i have invested in a
company called mind mad which does
it's now public and it basically um
is doing scheduled trials with the fda
level one level two level three
in micro dosing psychedelics to see if
in some way it can help with opioid
addiction or
anxiety or alcoholism and all these
afflictions that there really haven't
been any new drugs for in 35 years
that intrigues me because it's legal and
it's not being done recreationally
but that's different than drugs same
thing in that interview thing i talked
about earlier and i said okay wait a sec
you come to me and this has happened you
know sometimes very
interesting engineers come in i know
they're stoned
i can smell it if it's you know if
they've blown a joint they've had it
i can smell it it's just me
the answer is no i don't care for in a
state where it's legal
i don't like drugs because i'm pretty
happy
just marching on the way i am and i
don't want to change
but i also want to i don't take any
risks i don't want to mess with stuff
that messes with my head just a personal
opinion
and you could say well you know i like
to smoke spliff once in a while i get
all that
i'm just telling you what i do generally
speaking the people that i've known to
be very very successful
they get high on winning they get high
on moving forward they get high on
business and being successful
i will say this about one drug that you
know
i've been around for years because in
the television industry you see this all
the time
you see it in the bathrooms or whatever
cocaine that's a bad drug
it's a bad drug in every way i don't
know anybody that's been able to manage
that drug anybody that i know that's
gotten into it for a long period of time
it's been a real bad outcome including
death
really sucks but destroyed lives
discouraged marriages destroyed
businesses
i mean talk about changing behavior talk
about unhealthy i mean it's just
brutal and i get people's attraction to
it
but i don't believe that that's a drug
that you can have a little bit of
that's not how that one works so you're
gonna have to make your own decision
but for me i don't want anybody working
in any of my companies
that's doing coke because i know the
outcome it's
never good and when i find out they are
i'm sorry that's
you know i try and get them help but
very often it's not a drug you can get
off easily and i'm just i'm just saying
i understand addiction i got it but if
you have a choice
is what i'm saying and we're still on
the cocaine issue
you don't find cocaine associated with
success
you just don't you don't not over a
short period of time or a long period of
time so my advice to you
don't mess with it it's that simple if
you can completely avoid it do that if
you have to try it
be very cautious and conscious
of where it takes a lot of people to a
really
bad place okay last on cindy rose's list
was what about
sleep now i never thought about sleep
it was not a big deal to me sleep when
you can get some rest then i joined this
group called
the longevity league it's it's a bunch
of uh entrepreneurs that gather together
every couple of months sometimes it's a
zoom call sometimes it's a dinner
depending on what city they're all from
different places so
sometimes they meet you know but they're
interested
in understanding how to maintain a
really healthy lifestyle
both for balance of work you know in
life and everything else but
there are certain things you can do that
are very very healthy
and one of them is sleep now i never
really got into it but
rem sleep deep sleep how much sleep you
know
i used to think i don't need eight hours
sleep well you do actually
it really really helps you become a much
better and more productive person now
there's all kinds of devices on the
market
um you know there's there's watches i
don't wear those electronic watches i
wouldn't be see den with one
i prefer the art of a hand-crafted piece
obviously but there's rings and other
things and you put them on
this is one of them and it basically
tracks your sleep
and it's there's there's dozens of
devices you can choose whatever you like
but the point is
monitoring sleep is really interesting
because you
start to realize certain things about
your lifestyle
i'm really good at taking a 20-minute
snooze in the middle of the day when i'm
traveling somewhere and i'm
in a car you know back of a limo or and
i'm on a plane flying somewhere
and i would have thought that's the same
valuable sleep
that it would be in the middle of the
night it's not now one of the things
about sleep you should know
um and this is i found this out just you
know by just monitoring my own sleep
i love wine i'm in the wine business
i've talked about that a lot i love to
drink wine with dinners it turns out
the later you drink any alcohol the more
it screws up your sleep which is
heartbreaking for me because i just love
wine
and i've had to modify a little bit
instead of you know drinking wine
let's say i'm gonna have dinner at eight
o'clock or something or even worse it's
gonna be much later because
miami where i hang up quite quite a bit
it's a very late lifestyle sometimes
dinner's at 11. i don't drink at 11
o'clock at night anymore because it
totally screws up my sleep it reduces my
rem
sleep and reduces my deep sleep and you
can see the results off any device that
monitors your sleep
it's brutal so you know maybe you have a
drink at six or
seven i mean i don't know if you can do
this but i'm just telling you
over a long period of time screwing up
your sleep every night because you're
drinking
is really stupid that's my view so you
have to modify
maybe your weekends you ignore this but
at some point you really don't want to
mess up your rem sleep and your deep
sleep with alcohol
that's the one big change that i've put
into my life and it's really helped me
quite a bit it gives me a lot more
energy in the morning you'd be amazed
how fantastic you feel after a solid
eight hours sleep with a good cycle of
deep sleep
and rem sleep i mean you get up bouncing
out you're just ready to
take the world on it's fantastic what
screws that up
too much alcohol late at night or any
alcohol really close to when you go to
sleep
and i don't it's just the way it is i
mean you know it technically you'd be
better off drinking wine at nine in the
morning
which is crazy not recommending that but
you want to get it as far away from when
you're sleeping as you possibly can
either you give up alcohol completely
which i'm not prepared to do because i'm
in that business
or you modify your use of it so i've got
a couple of reasons for this the sleep
thing i don't want to do too many
calories knowing it's 160 calories
a glass so maybe a couple of glasses of
wine
three maxerino like that's max because
that's a ton of calories
but it takes a toll on your sleep so
that's kind of a little bit of a
snapshot about
um how for you know cindy rose all these
things fit together you're going to find
that successful people
have one way or another dealt with drugs
dealt with alcohol worked out the whole
sleep thing and figured out grooming and
fashion they found a path through all
that
and they've made a lifestyle choice you
can too
but it's got to be conscious you're
going to
want to do that and and for the guys
that are you know constantly worried
about their weight ah
get over it i mean look as long as it
doesn't make you unhappy about the way
you feel about yourself you can be
any body style or any weight that's cool
but if you want to modify it which seems
to be an obsession with about a third of
the population you have to change your
lifestyle
there's no for me dieting just doesn't
work you know and i've
and it doesn't really work for most
people starving yourself making yourself
miserable really stupid
changing your lifestyle small
modifications watch
over months how you shed the pounds so
we talked about a lot of stuff on this
um
i've dealt with all these issues myself
i've kind of found my path
bottom line let's end it this way you
want to get up in the morning and feel
great about the day you're going to be
in whatever it is you do
and so much of that is based around
things you have control over
what you eat what you drink the drugs
you take
you know how much sleep you get you were
gifted with control over those things in
many many many ways
and it's really up to you to make the
decision to do it
or not but that's the part i like the
most about cindy rose's question
pretty well everything on that list
she can do right or she can do wrong if
you like that video
wait did you see my next one don't
forget to click right over here
and subscribe